yeah I learned about kosher you guys  know what kosher is yeah you know like  the front of the atom right right you  don't eat like they kill their own  animals but you have to get the prey on  it it has to die immediately it has to  be an instant kill If It suffers then  you can't eat it oh yeah yeah yeah who  defines the suffering part what if it's  like headshots  headshots do you guys follow any of  those hardcore nature Pages absolutely  Nature's Metals real nice house [ __ ]  some animals are you can see a Buff Ass  Buck or something when you see that guy  on the forest like this guy will run me  over and then you see like a lion like  bite like bite my tail like they just go  they just give up you don't think he  understands how strong a lion's bite you  act like it's us biting it like if they  Chomp the whole leg then you can get it  it barely bits some hairs and you just  see them give up like oh you know let's  bring a lion in here we need to get bit